what's going on people in this video
we're about to break down episode 25 of
attack on titan season 4 in which this
new alliance to stop the rumbling runs
into a few problems the events of this
episode laid the foundation for an
all-out war between the scouts and the
aegiris and in this video i'll be
explaining exactly how it happened as
well as the hidden meanings and
references that you might have missed
before we get into it though i'd really
appreciate if you smash that like button
and subscribe if you haven't already as
it does help out the channel
okay so in the last episode hanji and
levi joined forces with general magath
and the car titan and there were two
main reasons why this happened reason
number one was that the captain was
willing to do whatever it takes to get
revenge on the beast titan even if that
meant siding with the enemy reason
number two was that hanji didn't agree
with aaron's plan to kill millions of
innocent people and so forming an
alliance was their best chance at
stopping the rumbling
now later that same night we saw how
jean was just sitting in his bedroom
with his hands covering his ears and
episode 25 shows us this same moment but
from a different perspective in this
scene the commander is outside his
window trying to recruit him to join the
alliance while he was trying his best to
pretend he didn't hear it jean knows for
a fact that if he just ignores hanji
then he can live a comfortable life on
the island just like he used to talk
about in the cadets earlier that day
flock even gave him a personal guarantee
that this would happen and he fantasizes
about the future life of luxury he's
going to have
one small detail about this fantasy is
that his imaginary future wife has a
scar on her right cheek identical to
mikasa and in addition she also has
similar black hair the scar is such a
precise detail that it basically
confirms that in jean's ideal future
he's married to mikasa and they have at
least one baby
anyway in the end his conscience
wouldn't allow him to ignore the
commander and he went outside to at
least hear what they had to say
as he and mikasa listened on hanji
explained their point of view which is
that aaron needs to be stopped because
killing everyone outside the wars is
taking things too far
even though the rumbling will
technically save people on the island
that shouldn't justify violence on this
scale and as a result mikasa does agree
to join the alliance on the other hand
jon didn't agree with hanji so easily
and to be fair he did have a good reason
the way he sees it if they do somehow
manage to stop aaron then for decades to
come anyone who survives the rumbling
will only feel more hatred and fear
towards the island in his mind it's
likely that at some point in the future
parodies will be completely destroyed by
other nations given that no one would
ever feel safe until they're wiped out
in response hanji tried to argue that
there might be some possible scenarios
where they could delay the world from
destroying them but again jon highlights
that they tried to do this once before
and it didn't work
what he's referring to here is the time
skip between seasons 3 and 4 in which
the scouts tried to find peaceful ways
to defend themselves without the
rumbling ultimately their search was
unsuccessful leading aaron to feel like
the only way he could protect the people
he cares about was to wipe out the rest
of humanity
despite that hanji stuck to her guns and
she maintained that rumbling the planet
was unethical and believed that their
fallen comrades also would never agree
to this massacre during this sequence
the vestiges of several former scouts
then appeared behind them and this
moment was a direct parallel to
commander irvin in the battle of
shiganchina the commander said that he
felt like their dead comrades were
watching them and now as hanji says a
similar thing evan has joined those
fallen soldiers that once stood behind
him
when it comes to drawn's choice about
whether he would join the alliance
seeing marco's spirit is what helped him
to make that decision and i'll explain
why
four years earlier when marco was being
cremated jean thought back to a
conversation they had in which his
friend praised him for knowing what
needs to be done those specific words
about knowing what needs to be done are
what helped him to make the difficult
choice to join the survey corps because
deep down he knew it was the right thing
to do
in the present day history then repeats
itself as by looking at his old friend
he realized that the right thing to do
in this situation is to join the
alliance that's why in the last episode
he said that ashi bones would have never
forgiven him if he didn't help referring
to marcos bones the day of his cremation
now flashing forward a bit the newly
formed alliance are awkwardly gathered
around the fire with everyone either
standing or sitting in complete silence
hanji breaks the ice by asking for help
with the food and this eventually leads
to the first of four main arguments in
this episode the core of this first
argument is really about which side has
been morally justified in the action so
far and i'll try to break it down step
by step
firstly general mcgath believes that
marley is on the side of justice while
parodies is on the side of evil and his
reasoning is pretty straightforward from
his perspective the marlins were right
to do everything they've done since
their fears about the rumbling turned
out to be 100 true
on top of that the fact that scouts are
helping to undo the mess that they
themselves helped create is basically an
admission that they've been fighting for
the wrong side this whole time however
jean disagrees with this obviously and
he reminds the general that all of this
is only happening because of marley's
own actions if the malians hadn't kept
sending titans for a century then the
people of the island would have never
had to fight back as hard as they did
and aaron's mother never would have been
eaten by a titan if she wasn't eaten
then it's unlikely aaron would have the
resolve to kill every single human
outside the walls meaning that in that
way it is marley's fault that being said
the general counters this by pointing
out that it was actually aliens who
began this conflict 2000 years ago
historically speaking the albion empire
were the first ones to attack mali with
the power of the titans and that
domination lasted for nearly the full
2000 years looking at things from this
angle malians have suffered at the hands
of titans for far longer than the people
of the island so mcgath doesn't really
feel much sympathy for the things that
jean was talking about
anyway hanji then butts in to put an end
to this particular debate but it didn't
take long for things to heat up again
with annie questioning whether the
scouts are prepared to kill aaron
being the rational person that she is
annie thinks that if they're going to
stop the rumbling then that means being
ready to kill him if they have to by
contrast arm and mikasa don't think that
killing should be their main option and
they're hoping to speak with aaron to
potentially talk him out of it annie's
argument is that if aaron has enough
conviction to murder the entire human
race then it's unlikely his mind is
going to be changed by the power of
friendship
following this she points out that even
if they do get a chance to speak with
him if he refuses to stop then that will
only create a civil war between this new
alliance on one side you have the
warriors trying to kill aaron to defend
their homeland while on the other side
he'd have the scouts who'd be fighting
against the warriors to protect him
annie knows this scenario is possible
because she's seen firsthand that
nothing is more important to mikasa than
aaron's safety one of my favorite
examples of this was during the lost
girl spin-off manga which had a special
chapter set during their time in the
cadets in that chapter mikasa went out
of her way to confront annie about her
special ring and warned her not to use
it while doing hand-to-hand combat with
aaron for that reason this prediction
about a civil war is realistic but
mikasa takes it as a threat and the two
of them prepared to fight there and then
around the campfire
to me this moment was reminiscent of
this scene from season 1 because in both
situations mikasa was quick to draw her
weapon against annie while everyone else
was just standing around
in any case the situation does start to
calm down after the female titan
explains her personal motivations and
she goes on to say that she hopes they
can talk eren out of it and if they can
do that then there shouldn't be a
problem between them
now before we move on to the next
argument there was actually a brief
moment where all the characters just sat
down in peace during this scene hanji
explains their plan to reach the
founding titan and essentially
everything depends on the azimubito clan
earlier this season it was shown that
his invented a new type of flying boat
and kyomi brought it to the island so
they could use it to observe the
rumbling with the malian airships having
now gone back home this flying boat is
their last remaining option to chase
after aaron but the problem with this
plan is that they don't know the
founder's location if they just fly
around looking for him aimlessly then
they will inevitably run out of fuel so
what they need is solid information
about which direction he's heading this
is where yelena comes in as mcgath
brought her along because she's the one
person who might know this besides flock
it's important for us to remember that
even the euthanization plan involved
doing a small scale rumbling so it's
likely that she does have an idea of
where the titans are going
based on what mcgath knows he assumes
that janina should at least be able to
make a guess about it but as the leader
of the anti-malian volunteers she didn't
exactly want to help out marley's
highest ranking officer
although her hatred for marley has been
part of her character from the beginning
connie was still slightly confused by
her refusal since her home country is
going to be trampled if they don't find
eren
the whole reason the volunteers came to
the island in the first place was for
the revival of their homelands so it
didn't make any sense that she wasn't
willing to help however this was the
point in the episode in which the truth
about yelena's past was revealed and it
was a lot different to the story she
gave when they first arrived as it turns
out she's been lying about her heritage
the entire time and in fact she's a
pure-blooded marlian just like magath
after the raid in liberio pique did some
digging into elena's pass since the car
titan remembered she was a follower of
zeke
during their investigation they
discovered that she was born in mali to
a regular family and it was only after
she met the beast titan that she began
pretending she was from somewhere else
if you want to understand why she made
up this fantasy then it's worth flashing
back to episode 16 which gave us a hint
about her underlying motivation to put
it simply yelena was obsessed with the
idea of zeke making history and becoming
a legend and she wanted to be part of
that story her belief was that if the
euthanization plan succeeded it would be
spoken about for thousands of years as
she wanted to be in the history books as
a girl from a tiny nation invaded by
mali that gathered people together and
made it possible
in response to pique revealing her
secret yelena then proceeds to roast
everyone the way she sees it they've
ruined the lives of countless innocent
people whether it was by trampling them
blowing them up having them eaten by
titans and you know having done all of
that they think that stopping the
rumbling will somehow make up for it
this is why yelena finds it ironic that
they're even trying to judge her and
during her speech she singled out
specific people for their actions
including annie and reiner this leads us
to the final big argument of the episode
which surrounds the truth about what the
warriors did to marco back in season 1
the scouts realized that annie had
something to do with his death since she
had taken his odm gear and tried to
pretend like it was her own armin
noticed this connection pretty much
straight away as he'd personally been
helping marco with maintenance and knew
the equipment belonged to him that being
said none of the scouts actually knew
the full truth about how he died until
this scene around the fire reiner
explains to the group how marco overhead
a conversation between him and bertolt
in which they basically confirmed they
were titan shifters if they allowed him
to live then it was all but guaranteed
they'd be found out so to preserve their
secret reiner pinned him down while
annie removed his gear following that it
was only a matter of time until a titan
showed up and the three warriors watched
on in horror as it began to eat him as
we know the guilt from this moment was
too much for ryan to process and it led
to the origin of his split personality
these two personalities were his way of
coping with the grief with one of them
being a soldier that cared about his
fellow eldians while the other was a
warrior that wanted to capture the
founding titan and return back to mali
here he explains how the soldier
personality took over while marco was
being eaten and an interesting detail
was that he went on to kill the time
that did it
following this confession reiner kept on
apologizing for his actions even after
jon asked him to stop and the reason he
wouldn't shut up is because he hates
himself even after all these years he's
never been able to forgive himself for
the things he's done since none of the
people he killed were island devils like
he was led to believe by mali
eventually he just keeps on talking
until jean punches him in the face and
this savage beatdown was him releasing
all the pent-up anger he felt towards
rainer and you know the fact that the
warrior just sat back and let it happen
it's another indication of how little he
thinks of himself as armin and connie go
to hold him back jean then starts
kicking rhino but his second kick does
accidentally hit gabby who jumped in to
defend her cousin
despite being the victim in the
situation she's the one who apologizes
as she goes on to explain the mentality
that both her and reina used to have
their goal was to eliminate the devils
on the island so that the rest of the
world would accept them as good aldians
but as a result of their actions they're
now going to lose everything an
important thing worth noticing here is
that general mcgath was listening to the
whole thing and he realizes that
everything gabby just said was taught to
her by marley her belief that they could
be accepted by killing the island devils
that's something that the general likely
had a hand in teaching them and it's why
he begins to reach out there's a part of
mcgath that understands how disgraceful
mali is for turning these kids into
brainwashed child soldiers but for now
he's not fully ready to accept that
given that he's still trying to convince
himself that they're the good guys
for that reason he puts his hand down
however there is a clear look of regret
on his face
the following day the alliance then make
their way to the harbour which is where
the flying boat is being held and along
the way jean apologizes to gabby for
what he did
as they get closer to their destination
the car tyson already went ahead to take
a look at things and she reports back
that the jaegers have locked the place
down thanks to the steam engine they
were able to travel to the harbour way
faster than the scouts and on the inside
flock is shown to be holding kyomiya as
a hostage
if you're wondering how flock need to do
all of this is because in the last
episode he noticed that mixer had gone
missing this must have caused him to get
suspicious about what she was planning
and so to be safe he decided to detain
her relatives in the asian clan although
he doesn't know for sure what they're
gonna do one thing he does know is that
by securing this place there's no way
anyone can try and stop the rumbling
because you know without the flying boat
it's basically impossible on top of that
the azimut beta were the only ones who
can get the flying boat ready so if the
alliance is going to reach aaron then
they somehow need to get through all of
these jaegers and save the asian clan
without getting them killed
anyhow that was my breakdown for episode
25 of attack on titan season 4 and if
this video helped you understand the
episode in any way then i'd appreciate
if you dropped a comment down below and
smash that sub button
also as some of you noticed i wasn't
able to do a review last week due to
personal reasons for episode 24 however
sometime in april or may i will be doing
a full breakdown of part two just like i
did for part one
however sometime in april or may i will
be doing a full breakdown of part two
just like i did for part one thanks for
watching as always and until the next
one peace out